all right here we go thunderhorse land
haha watch out for the blue chicken oh I
could finish my opponent off so easily
not going to though not going to get out
of there
sneak attack oh my square weaknesses
height squares like squares take that
pond you know you want them
I'm getting a piece back move rook right
here F 2 power suggestion keep going
hot push is good I could take here and
then take the rook I'm gonna pin after
this now I could do this it's card my
knight jump my knight in here
it's whit's check it spawn is hit I can
take it with the check grab that guy my
knight is a monster ok this pond has
passed can't be caught
cleans coming up design time
Kartik er none of the above
where is that mean back to terming -
okay thunderhorse land Oh
what do you do without a queen night
what do you do without a queen night I
would much rather not have a clean night
you have to get up you'll just have to
get used to this setup I could have
taken that guy setup is uh that's all I
really have okay I'll take a pod then
queen doing something Oh free queen and
check I want to open up the h-file
sneaky mate in each seven h7h seven easy
to miss h7 is still on oh that's me aged
seven back to tournament nine six five
and a bunch of two's double those points
no night again no night okay all right I
want I do this so I could close up the
center in case they get excited about
some pond pushes okay keep going ponies'
keep going ponies get my clean-up on
push again I'm not afraid of you can get
queenside castle pawn push I might need
to take otherwise the knight jumps in
here I'm gonna have to deal with them Oh
is he a monster what is he a monster or
what keep it closed over here please
please keep it closed
oh boy I am in a dangerous position oh
man
pawn takes I take the knight and then
I'm on the rook keep it closed
oh this rook is such a pain okay come on
get rid of that night get rid of that
night he needs to go whoa
get out of there light-square bishop
would you come to life already oh man
oh that it's gonna kill me
we gotta stop that knife from jumping in
there um right here open up this this
file okay trickiness um oh I'm so dead I
feel it oh yeah I know I know I know
it's happening why am I not moving two
points I got to do that oh that's a bad
move
oh my goodness lieutenant Hertz is so
dangerous oh man
pre moves everywhere how many times are
like Queen hanging Wow one of the most
dangerous tournaments around the Thunder
Thunder horse I can't even say it that's
how dangerous it is
once again stuff just never makes sense
never man are you sick of looking at
this setup I bet you are I bet you are I
know how you feel
I really do no no trays I could blue
chicken my opponent any second F pine
strikes
let's get castled no no that's what I
say whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa dropping
the farm
I'm officially dropping the farm oh my
goodness Mike oh that's a fork I get I
get on in trouble though Oh the night's
gonna kill me
where is he I'm in big trouble what is
my bishop doing can somebody tell me
please just run and hide
run and hide Oh deadly Forks everywhere
still there I'm so dead can I save this
what is look at my bishop what a stupid
stupid piece what a stupid stupid piece
help oh that was a free queen oh that's
exactly what I needed I needed a free
queen oh that's a free rook come on bear
rook I'm get their pawns so one king
upon in game can I win this one without
losing on time
unlike that tournament keep coming upon
keep going pond oh I did it wrong
oh I did it in the wrong order
oh my goodness I want to turn upon winds
over-queen deadly oh it's tough to
stomach man aren't they oh man I know
that feeling I just know it I know that
feeling all too well because it happens
to me too those are painful I know they
are I know they are paying for oh yeah
one pod versus a queen
was he a tough tough cookie or what back
to tournament land quick kill sort of a
non mover okay oh let's try this I get
the I should target that weak point I'm
gonna move Oh No let's try this again
if check I just run away at Mike well
I'd have to wouldn't I what else you
think you're gonna do stop this bishop
was gonna play here stopping this
advance this rook is opposite my king
scary scary situation
what is that Knight up to he's just bad
news he has bad news written all over
him
get out of there I wish I could castle
but I can that is one thing that I am
wishing for I wish that I could castle
but I can that my king is gonna start
running oh my goodness what's happening
I could throw in some checks maybe
that'll work out someday you know you're
having a tough day when you have to play
real gauge to let me tell you about that
hang on hang on tricky stuff my knight
is a he's developed classically now no
I'm on the night I'm on the Queen they
missed it my rook is coming - oh my
mouse slipped out I didn't take - Queen
seventeen seconds uh what a bad Mouse if
I don't even realize
check it this guy queen trade no no no
no no no just don't even move the Queen
why am I thinking of moving the Queen oh
oh no is that me
my King needs to go somewhere else let's
do that nine seconds right here
tricky Knights time burners time burner
time Oh time burners oh my goodness
they're doing time brands on me oh my
goodness oh it's just great
crazy thunderhorse okay Queen Knight is
gone man having a laughing fit laughing
fit let's play this before this
otherwise Bishop b5 I was gonna say that
play this play this and then that fine
push that's enough that is enough
no this position shall remain closed
hang on I want to get this info I think
you could turn out good forks forks
could be good get out of there okay I
want this pawn to be able to move let's
see if we can make that happen
it's castle oh they're gonna help me out
they're gonna take their I think you
know you want to take ok night let's do
something all right let's just take here
and then oh man
pawn push is gonna be good it gives this
Knight this square yeah here he comes
what a shame what a shame
okay I got it I got a defend against
that 27 seconds not a lot of time all
right
it's Knights there to stay can I get rid
of him very quickly
he's the number one priority mmm okay
take a look I guess
actually he's I'm so dead no no
I couldn't connect my rooks if the
knight played their double Oryx blades
pins it's got to be scary through that
night he needs to go he's not going
though
what a stupid light square bishop okay
I'm getting two pieces here try my clean
back get that pawn well take that not
not like take that you know what I mean
I mean literally take that take that
pawn hey God my bishops gonna oh no no
no I don't want to allow the Queen in
there
ah don't know how the Queen then I would
check where are those time burners oh I
got the Queen with check I should just
move my knight Queen here no matter what
take this no matter what here no matter
what here no matter what
dr. terminar down on time sixty-two
56:51 lucky lucky beagle seventeen
minutes left
we're not even at the halfway point not
even there yet
alrighty
let's do that okay
and that night gonna move let's force
them to move um dark my dark squares I
want to get my knight in here I think
inside castle I'm push pawn push keep
stuff closed okay
pawn push I think I'm close to getting
something I was ready to push that pine
I'd get hit with a fork
I'd have been bad very bad pawns on dark
squares maybe that night out of there
too dangerous
get this Knight out of there it's he
trapped no he's not jump my knight in
right here it's maybe set up some sneaky
stuff and I want to keep the default
close I'm on the Queen I forgot about
that you been better I like my knight
too much but I think I have to get some
more material back think I need to do
that pressure on this pond a third time
now I've pressure Oh pressure on this
point there's Queen check can you
believe that I want to keep the Queen's
on the board
eighteen seconds I'm on the rook okay
pressure on f7 I'm in a pen soon Queen
takes pawn queen check defending this
I'm on this with check I could take my
Queen takes Knight oh I should've taken
with my queen they're down on time I was
actually winning that eighty five eighty
seventy two alright the last fourteen
minutes and change why did I play this
tournament why did I decide
oh my goodness I'm only down upon Wow
okay this is interesting I'm gonna I'm
gonna like to play in the queenside play
on the side where you have more open
lines oh I have open lines over here
it's the Smith Maura this is the this is
the Smith Laura um it Maura where I have
um I have space on the queenside okay I
was gonna blow up in here okay bad stuff
is about to happen are you ready for it
I'm not ready for it
oh boy get out of there night I might be
trapped hit the Queen okay the night oh
I can't do that I'm pinned darn it
I'm gonna take that on the bishop I'm on
the night I missed that watch out for
mates I'm not the dark square Bishop
might be some sax probably yes actually
I could take that Bishop takes isn't um
what am I getting at oh I can do this I
think my getting made it I'm not dark
squares guard my dark squares oh my
goodness I can't take that take the
bishop 25 seconds I actually have a lead
time wise okay this is good Queen takes
me that pun get over here King position
give me that pun and then which problem
I want to save this one's more important
that ponds going nowhere let me make
sure that this pond does not get taken
and then I could come all the way over
here take my time okay they're down on
time back to tournament 90 100 90 90 90
whoa
no Queen Knight 12 minutes remaining
it's this guy rated
okay let's keep going
I gotta go off my H funds okay they're
giving me something to work with here oh
I would I do that
I meant to my queen
I want to cry man I want to cry take
that pawn I'm on the Queen oh this is
working out I think they missed it oh
that's exactly what I needed
now this Knight needs to go somewhere
else he's just bad news written all over
him
all over him oh my goodness oh my
goodness that was so scary
oh I can't do that I want to keep my
queen oh my goodness these Knights are
way too tricky way way too tricky 16
seconds take that night rooks move
laterally oh yes oh my goodness
they've moved laterally come on come on
g7 I have to sneeze - fun fact fun fact
that was great I really needed to know
that oh my goodness
take care no matter what
they're down on time I couldn't breathe
breathe I needed sneeze 110 106 101
current Fisher
no Queen night it's gonna feel so much
better when I get to play with the full
deck here full deck a full group of
chess pieces would be nice one day one
day okay my name wants to jump on f4 and
not just yet okay let's go on this side
watch my knight he's a traveler he is a
traveler no keep it closed let's come up
here let's prepare stuff yes what a
wonderful comment let's prepare stuff
it's exactly what I was thinking
if I were you I would prepare stuff
there's my opponent preparing get out of
there night out of my house right square
okay my bishop looks like an idiot okay
let's do that somehow I think it's right
I was ready to Castle I can't castle run
over here King is it safe is it safe
over here got a block 20 seconds 20
seconds King do something constructive
what a big dummy my pawns are holding
their ground surprisingly no no I want
that pond to change
it's a free night should I just push
that pond kill that night and then
contest this file got the Queen I here
activity well that's a rook oh I thought
I lost Sun time they're down on time 4.3
seconds 148 140 130 Pat okay eight
minutes remaining I'm down a night
why am i playing so opened okay take
that pond all right even take that pun
on this pond in the night if the pond
pushes dark square weaknesses they miss
that you're gonna get my rook but I
should be having compensation mine I
could move main threats here we go
deadly deadly deadly made on g7 back to
tournament 150 160 160 is up there 148
just behind 147 minutes remaining
okay but because oh my goodness oh my
goodness a full deck I was just talking
about this full deck is here okay
that pom pushes I could grab that pond
could grab this because of the pin my
knight is a monster I think I think he
is a monster in that pond right
get rid of their light square bishop
okay
number one defender I want to get rid of
I want to keep this night around he's
got to be a giant pest when I played
this move I was ready to get forked
again keep this in here I should still
have compensation pom push it might
nitrite in here that has to be really
really good clock situation I think I
just want to keep throwing my pawns up
here keep rolling keep going actually
I'm dropping this now defend this with
my queen my bishop doing something get
my pawn push watch out for mate here
pawn push serious serious threats
happening that's actually leading to
mate less than 10 seconds back to
tournament 170 170 160 158 five minutes
remaining
Queen Knight nowhere to be seen
can I get my bishop there yes it was a
dangerous that was a dangerous idea that
I just went forward with can I get on
those light squares and do some weakness
provoke this pawn push hit this pine
more weaknesses on push again it weakens
the dark square diagonal is my knight I
get on these dark squares next my knight
needs to come over here I think put up
the G file let's try this maybe we get
this advance and no it's close where
does my knight want to be I'm not sure I
think this thing is right oh they got
the sneeze again what's going on
I'll pawn push is gonna kill me I should
have just taken the night let's try it
I'm gonna keep my tricky night around
keep that tricky night around very
important very very important piece get
out of that nonsense keep the Queens on
the board 23 seconds let's try this
thrown a check I'm not sure if it's good
it's not good could take the night if it
goes here it might be tempting night
here oh oh okay I have a threat okay I
have to take they're gonna do a pawn
push no they didn't got the Queen 12
seconds I get that night come my queen
get active yes she can Han push I'm
getting more I'm getting material I get
this pawn next I think yes and then get
off of this same file now the bishop no
matter what I'm gonna take here rook and
pawn endgame five seconds they're down
on time back to chairman 190 184 178
three minutes forty seconds
xanga keep thinking how I can do the
blue chicken gambit queenside castle
your opponent's clock burns unless they
fixed it um okay I came here pawn push
get to f4 maybe get my Queen in the
corner let's keep this closed it's best
I can get this pawn push you okay
defend stuff like a queenside castle
maybe I should look to do that you know
my king over here Queen here
that's night that night's gonna be
annoying all right let's see if this
works can actually take there enough now
I have enough defense for pomp crushes
threatening Forks threatening Forks I'll
push here maybe take the knight I almost
missed that play Knight here actually I
could take I want to get my queen doing
something better okay
my knight really can't move or can II
keep my knight I want to be able to
maintain my knight there ah what a shot
very nice take that pawn next think have
to hold that together my queen is stupid
what a stupid Queen
oh my queen do something let's I got it
I got to stir stuff up okay shut that
diagonal down should have just taken
that I'm pretty sure sexualize the queen
don't fall for mates they're down on
time back - chairman - ten - Oh for 132
left maybe this game would finish maybe
127 125 huh I could blue chicken my way
to victory are they gonna resign ah a
non mover is exactly what I needed this
could be very timely 15 second rule
mistakes have been doubled ah
they moved I gotta try and win quick
when I'm - a piece maybe that ha I could
do some damage oh my goodness I got a
rug that was a free rug if that Knight
moves I get to clean oh my goodness
they're just throwing everything at me
ah kitchen sink land they resigned back
to tournament 230 oh I think I clinched
it - 32 or 40 even if that guy wins no
Queen rook and I get overly excited over
these or what I do I do don't I
I should be considering taking that
night and then pushing because now he's
a big dummy
or is he its attack on this side space
advantage pawn push night here so that
the knight can't make use of that square
first support my pawn and then advance
pawn push on push they've been assigned
cubits have been assigned what is it
Oh first place can fail you thunderhorse
it's been a while all right
2:30 that guy did win - 32 24 198 180
188 188 a lot of tiebreakers there for
that fourth place position okay all
right good games